resilience our dedication it was a
celebrated moment for the world nearly a
year into the pandemic a vaccine against
Kobe 19. and the first to administer it
a Filipino nurse in the United Kingdom
her name May Parsons
the moment has landed her in her home
Country's new international campaign we
give the world her best
but this campaign is solely for the
purpose of elevating the Filipinos and
making them feel proud and be seen and
to say that actually you do give your
best wherever you may be whatever
specialty you are in whatever industry
you chose
the government has clarified it isn't
meant to replace the popular it's more
fun in the Philippines tourism slogan
DJ I am the Philippines
beyond the purpose of the campaign the
message itself is in question
the country's tourism secretary says it
is a fact that the Philippines gives the
world its best every day thousands of
Filipinos leave to work as nurses
teachers caregivers and domestic helpers
abroad but critics ask at what cost
nearly 2 million Filipinos work abroad
last year they sent home more than 36
billion dollars their annual remittances
account for around nine percent of GDP
we know that the ads are targeting
um foreign governments and foreign
corporations to essentially for us it
means that it's selling Filipino labor
instead of addressing the root problems
that forces our people to migrate
overseas
Parsons acknowledges to brain drain but
she says there isn't a shortage of
nurses in the Philippines it's just that
they choose to pursue other jobs or
leave the country for their own good if
you want them to have the best future
possible for themselves they've got to
do that decision themselves and if
they're they couldn't find it in the
Philippines they are within their rights
to find it somewhere else both critics
and Parsons agree the government needs
to improve conditions to encourage
professionals and workers to stay
but one sees the ads as a source of
Pride the other the continuing promotion
of Labor export
Barn below Al Jazeera Manila